[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 actualité et idées de sorties
pour bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines voici le programme de ce 14
janvier un projet d'envergure qui
devrait se concrétiser dès cette année à
saint germain en laye le grand bassin du
domaine national va reprendre vie la
première pierre a été posée ce jeudi en
présence de la ministre de la culture
roselyne bachelot le 15 janvier 2002
l'équipe de formule 1 prost gp est basé
à guyancourt et mise en liquidation
judiciaire vingt ans après retour sur
cette aventure qui aura duré quatre ans
avec trois podiums décrochés en grand
prix et puis comme tous les vendredis
nos idées de sorties dans les yvelines
pour samedi et dimanche c'est dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission
et ce sera bien sûr avec mon acolyte du
vendredi bixente n'a rien senti steban
bonjour bischwihr gégory quels sont les
suggestions du jour aujourd'hui grégory
on va apprendre on va apprendre ce que
c'est que l'entomophagie on va aussi
fêter un anniversaire les 400 ans de
quelqu'un et enfin on va au brunch et et
ce sera tout à l'heure bien sûr dans le
7-8 week end
un taux d'incidence proche des 3500 cas
pour 100000 habitants dans les yvelines
et dans le même temps de grandes files
d'attentes pour se faire dépister contre
le coc vite 19 face à la déferlante du
variant omicron le vaccinodromes de
saint quentin en yvelines se transforme
en centre de test géant annonce de
l'agglomération dès lundi le site sera
en capacité de réaliser 500 tests
antigénique par jour trente mille ans
tous ont été commandé en urgence ces
tests seront accessibles uniquement sur
rendez vous à prendre sur la plateforme
d' octobre ils seront à réaliser dans un
espace du vélodrome dédié du lundi au
vendredi de 9h à 15h par ailleurs l'
agence régionale de santé indique que
d'autres lieux de dépistage vont
s'ouvrir au centre de vaccination de
saint cyr l'école à poissy et via trois
taxis bus du département qui sillonnent
le territoire yvelinois les travaux
devraient prendre fin au printemps pour
une inauguration en septembre le grand
bassin du domaine nationale de saint
germain en laye va être recréés commandé
par louis xiv le nôtre le projet n'avait
pas pu être achevée avec le départ de la
cour vers versailles à la première
pierre a été posée ce jeudi en présence
de la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot et sur place mélanie poquet et
laura légaux
faire revivre la perspective des loges
le domaine nationale de saint germain en
laye va voir renaître son grand bassin
un projet initié par louis xiv pour
donner de l'éclat aux jardins de la
résidence royale l'enjeu principal si
vous voulez c'est la restauration d'une
image une image très forte qui est celle
de la perspective de le nôtre qui avait
été dénaturé par la disparition du
bassin et donc la composition va être
retrouvée on avait une composition
triangulaire avec deux petits bassins
proche du château est un très grand
bassin
dans laxe dans la perspective des loges
des travaux débutés il ya déjà plusieurs
mois avant la recréation du bassin la
première pierre a été symboliquement
déposée le jeudi 12 janvier aux
chantiers rendue possible grâce à
l'arrivée du tram 13 et une
correspondance avec le rer a c'est une
prouesse
technique considérable parce qu'on voit
bien que les structures les structures
de transport sont à arnaud à m un mètre
de profondeur et demandent des travaux
des travaux architecturaux extrêmement
précis et extrêmement complexe donc
coûteux c'est effectivement 6,55
millions d'euros pour restaurer pour
remettre cette cette pièce dos le projet
voit le jour grâce à un financement
collectif le ministère de la culture la
ville de saint germain en laye le
département des yvelines la région
ile-de-france et des mécènes privés la
particularité de ce domaine c'est
qu'avec l'arrivée du tram on va faire
une jonction entre le domaine et le parc
de saint germain jusqu'au parc de
versailles c'est unique ont recréé un
axe majeur de notre département est donc
bien évidemment ça va redonner beaucoup
de lustre et daf activités au domaine
un projet qui devrait prendre fin au
printemps prochain l'inauguration de
l'édifice est prévue le 17 septembre
2022 à l'occasion des journées
européennes du patrimoine
autre déplacement ministériel ce
vendredi dans les yvelines celui de la
secrétaire d'état sarah el aerial est
venu rendre visite à la maison des
associations de versailles pour échanger
avec les associations sur l'application
du cadre sanitaire dans les structures
ainsi que sur les conséquences du virus
sur les structures qui sont composés
bien sûr de bénévoles ces associations
une actualité une semaine surtout riche
en actualité dans les yvelines que
faut-il retenir en vous résume le tout
en 78 secondes
le projet de loi sur le post vaccinales
entraîne une vague de violence contre
les élus 60 aurait été menacé de mort
depuis le début de l'année selon le
ministère de l'intérieur et député des
yvelines ont également été visés le
masque en extérieur n'est plus
obligatoire dans le département le
tribunal administratif de versailles a
suspendu l'arrêté du préfet des yvelines
une mesure qui portait une atteinte
excessive à la liberté individuelle a
jugé l'instance grève inédite pour
dénoncer le protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles les syndicats d'enseignants
appelaient à débrayer mouvement soutenu
par les chefs d'établissements les
inspecteurs et les parents d'élèves 300
personnes ont manifesté devant la
préfecture à versailles près d'un
enseignant sur deux du premier degré
étaient mobilisés dans l'académie selon
le rectorat de nombreux maires sont
également non content du protocole dans
les écoles 37 édiles des yvelines ont
été créés au premier ministre jean
castex pour demander des changements il
souhaite notamment un allègement de la
charge de travail pour les directeurs et
enseignants et aussi la livraison rapide
d'autotest et de tests salivaires depuis
lundi votre pass navigo est également un
sésame culturel il vous permet d'obtenir
des réductions dans plus de 300 sites
franciliens 21 lieu dans les yvelines
quatre millions de personnes sont
concernées et puis les blinois jean
pierre garcin a conclu son 23e dakar il
était le co pilote de lionel baud / ph
racing le duo termine à la 31e place du
classement des autos dominé par le
qatarien nasser al attiyah
c'était il ya vingt ans le 15 janvier
2002 l'équipe de formule 1 prost gp basé
à guyancourt été mise en liquidation
judiciaire avec une dette de 30,5
millions d'euros et l'écurie dirigé de
1997 à 2001 par alain prost aura
décroché trois podiums retour sur cette
histoire avec michael est lui dedans
[Musique]
les pièces de la paix 02 100 par exemple
réalisé en ce moment dans l'atelier
derrière nous
vous êtes ici au contrôle de qualité
qu'est ce qu'on y fait on fait le
contrôle de toutes les pièces qui sont
montés sur la voiture c'est à dire ça va
de la petite rondelle en passant par les
boîtes de vitesses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas de sécurité à tous les
niveaux
il n'est pas question de
2 - touristes qu'ils soient financiers
qui soient morales qu'ils soient
l'arrivée des grands constructeurs on en
est sûr fait que les moyens sont
complètement disproportionnées c'est
devenu un championnat dans son sculpteur
pour trouver des financements d'espagne
s'est aussi beaucoup plus difficile la
situation économique n'aide pas le fait
qu'ils aient eu pas mal de fusions
acquisitions dans les années passent et
non plus 13 diminue le nom
[Musique]
ça commence avec des lots
comme des éléments de carrosserie qui
sont plutôt des souvenirs pour des
amateurs ou des passionnés de la formule
1 et 2 de l'écurie prost donc c'est des
éléments qui feront 500 euros enfin
entre 100 et 500 euros tout le monde
pourra y trouver une pièce un aileron un
triangle un élément personnel et
personnalisé prost
[Musique]
votre rubrique légal checking à présent
pour vérifier ce que disent les acteurs
de l'actualité raphaël mata duvignau du
collectif des surligneurs décrypte des
propos qui ont fait grand bruit ce du
président de la république sur les non
vaccinés
pour emmanuel macron un irresponsable
n'est plus citoyens dit-il à propos des
personnes non vaccinées heureusement
pour nous les responsabilités n'est pas
un critère légal de nom citoyenneté les
mots du président de la république nous
interpelle endroit et citoyen celui qui
principalement est ressortissant d'un
état dont il détient la nationalité et
qui bénéficie à ce titre du droit de
participer activement à l'exercice de la
souveraineté soit à travers ses
représentants soit directement par
référendum on le constate la vaccination
n'est pas en tout cas pas encore sauf à
modifier la constitution et le code
civil n'est pas un critère de
nationalité
changement alors d'angle d'attac un
irresponsable serait-il plutôt un
mauvais citoyen
cette notion existe indirectement
endroit puisque celui qui viole
gravement c'est drôle devoir de citoyen
peut être déchu de sa nationalité le
code civil énumère en effet différents
cas de citoyens indigne de la
nationalité française comme ceux
condamnés pour des actes portant
atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation ou condamnés pour des actes de
terrorisme
un citoyen peut également perdre ses
droits civiques droit de vote droit
d'éligibilité
s'il est condamné pénalement à ce titre
donc à ce jour aucun fondement juridique
ne permet d'intégrer les non vaccinés
dans la catégorie fictive des mauvais
citoyens sauf je le répète a créé des
infractions pénales spéciales ce qui
serait n'en doutons pas assez
problématique sur le plan juridique et
morale sous la terreur le tribunal
révolutionnaire orientait aimablement
les mauvais citoyens jugés comme tels
vers la guillotine malheureusement cette
option n'est plus envisageable
aujourd'hui on doit donc se rendre à
l'évidence un président reste
juridiquement en charge de tous ses
citoyens
ne lui reste plus qu'une solution
emmerder les nombres signer avec
différentes tracasseries administratives
si juridiquement cette solution et
réalistes et concrètes sur le plan des
symboles en revanche la présidente
devrais pas dire ça
allait on sort à présent dans les
yvelines dans ce site we came
bixente n'a rien senti steban de retour
en plateau pour vous livrer sa sélection
déjà un anniversaire important qu'on
fait ce week-end et cette année celui de
molière et on le célèbre aussi à
versailles mais à l'occasion des 400 ans
de sa naissance l'espace richaud
accueille l'exposition molière la
fabrique d'une gloire nationale du 15
janvier au 17 avril prochain elle
retrace la vie mais aussi l'héritage
culturel du dramaturge qu'on ne présente
plus reportage il y a quatre cents ans
jean baptiste poquelin voit le jour à
paris sur scène il deviendra molière
l'un des plus grands hommes des théâtres
français cette oeuvre étant une maquette
en volume et à l'échelle de la tentative
de reconstitution du décor du malade
imaginaire conforme à ce qu'on sait de
la création par molière en février 1673
cette maquette est l'une des 400 oeuvres
de l'exposition molière la fabrique
d'une gloire nationale elle investit à
partir du 15 janvier l'espace richaud de
la ville de versailles dans cette
exposition vous pourrez voir des
éléments patrimoniaux des grandes
peintures officiel des sculptures des
gravures quelques documents étaient
authentiques notamment une ordonnance
signée par le roi donne un molière
l'exclusivité de l'exploitation d'une de
ses pièces le malade imaginaire ce n'est
donc pas par hasard que versailles a
choisi d'accueillir cet événement
molière a joué plusieurs de ses pièces
dans les jardins du château il était
proche de la cour et notamment du roi
soleil un tel rapport de confiance entre
molière et le roi louis xiv car mon nom
il y avait une sorte d'exclusivité t1 34
siècles nous sépare de son oeuvre
pourtant le dramaturge et toujours sur
le devant de la scène il est devenu un
véritable mythe repris au théâtre mais
aussi au cinéma ou en dessin on a voulu
donner toute leur place aussi à des
oeuvres contemporaines actuelle un
graffiti de rues représentant un village
de molière un roman graphique une bande
dessinée du cinéma de façon à montrer
que molière est toujours vivant qu'il
est parmi nous et qu'il reste une source
très féconde d'inspiration non seulement
au théâtre mais également dans toute
sorte de mode d'expression artistique et
les deux cultures même quand les très
populaires
l'exposition prendra fin le 17 avril
prochain elle laissera place en juin au
mois molière le festival de théâtre et
de musique à versailles séquence
interview à présent dans ce set week-end
votre invité aujourd'hui bixente elle et
entomologiste en effet grégory
l'entomologie c'est la partie de la
zoologie qui traitent des insectes
l'objectif apprendre et qui plus est
c'est encore mieux en s'amusant et donc
nous recevons caroline picard
entomologiste et animatrice à la maison
des insectes de carrières sous poissy
bonjour bonjour pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la maison des insectes
vous êtes donc situé dans le nord des
yvelines à carrières sous poissy plus
précisément au niveau du parc du peuple
de l'herbe chez vous on retrouve une
exposition notamment permanente
présentée par l'opl donc l'office pour
les insectes et leur environnement dans
un but pédagogique de sensibilisation
petites bestioles
mais il ya aussi des événements plus
ponctuelles organisées par exemple vous
ouvrez un dimanche par mois et c'est
donc ce dimanche ce qui sera mis à
l'honneur c'est la relation entre les
hommes et les insectes pour commencer
donc vous parlerez d'entomologie qu'est
ce que c'est
c'est le fait de manger des insectes
c'est quelque chose dont on parle de
plus en plus on dit qu'on risque d'y
venir à un moment et c'est dans mon pays
européens et là l'idée c'est de discuter
avec un spécialiste donc avec philippe
le gall qui est
administrateur à l'opie donc à l'office
pour les insectes et qui est lui
spécialisé dans l'entomophagie et qui va
venir présenter un peu son métier qu'est
ce que l'on tomou flagy et quel avenir
il ya sur l'ontologie
sur ce dimanche là il abordera quelle
quelle thématique puisque sans lui on va
pas lui voler toute sa présentation mais
dans les grandes lignes il parlera de 2d
bien fait pour l'homme ben il va parler
de lancôme ont fléchi déjà à travers le
monde un petit peu comment ça se fait
quelles espèces sont utilisés en
entomologie et puis voilà comment ça va
s'installer ou pas d'ailleurs en france
l'entomologiste ça peut avoir un avenir
pour l'alimentation justement c'est un
peu l'alimentation du futur on peut le
voir comme ça
je sais pas si on peut le voir comme ça
mais en tout cas c'est ce qui va être
traitée dimanche par chili il y aura
aussi du coût des ateliers tout au long
de la journée proposée en continu c'est
ça c'est ça en fait il y aura deux temps
d'un échange avec philippe 14h30 et à
16h30 et sinon la maison des insectes
elle est ouverte entre 11 heures et 18
heures en continu et donc l'équipe
d'animation de l'opi va proposer des
jeux des ateliers tout autour de
l'entomophagie et qui sera à destination
des tout-petits comme du public adulte
il y en a vraiment pour tous les âges
sur cette journée là aujourd'hui
pourquoi quelle est la vocation de la
maison des insectes de sensibiliser sur
le monde des petites bestioles c'est par
rapport à la peur qu'ont les gens des
fois vis-à-vis des insectes pourquoi du
coup la maison des insectes voilà alors
la maison des insectes à elle a été
pensée comme ça en tout cas c'est on a
voulu travailler sur les idées reçues
qu'on se fait sur les petites bêtes que
les petites date ça fait peur les
petites bêtes ça grouille ces méchants
etc
vraiment travailler tout ça est donc la
maison des insectes est normalement là
pour vivre une expérience avec les
insectes et rencontrer des insectes
vivants j'essaie justement c'est
sensibiliser de manière ludique ça se
fait en famille c'est sa famille entre
amis
et il ya vraiment pas d'âge pour
découvrir les insectes on a l'impression
que parce qu on est adulte on sait déjà
tout mais en fait il ya plein de gens
qui ont ressortent en ayant un prix déjà
plein de choses sur les insectes en
venant nous voir vous avez combien
d'insectes à la maison des insectes
justement atteint lorsque aussi on a une
quinzaine de terrariums d'insectes
vivant donc en nombre d'individus ça
fait beaucoup parce qu'ils vont être
certain terrarium il faut y avoir une
vingtaine ou trentaine d'individus par
terrarium et on a aussi une volière à
papillons où il ya une quarantaine
d'individus à l'intérieur vous êtes en
plus situé juste à côté du parc du
peuple de l'herbe est ce que l'idée
c'est ça c'est de venir se faire se
sensibiliser autour des insectes à la
maison des sectes et ensuite découvrir
par soi-même dans le parc voilà en fait
le la salle d'exposition donne sur le
parc du peuple de l'herbe donc c'est à
dire qu'on a vue sur le parc bon là même
si c'est pas trop la période mais l'idée
c'est que à la maison des insectes on va
montrer des insectes tropicaux dont qui
viennent un petit peu partout et de
faire le parallèle avec ce qu'on trouve
par chez nous et d'inciter les gens à
les voir dans leur jardin sur leur
balcon ou dans le parc à l'école les
petites bêtes qui s'y trouve est donc
rapidement vous avez d'autres
thématiques prévue pour 2022 sur des
événements ponctuels le dimanche en
dimanche par mois par exemple et bah du
coup voilà un dimanche par mois sauf
pendant les vacances ou là on reste
fermé toute l'année va être orientée sur
vraiment la relation
entre les petites bêtes et les hommes
donc en mars par exemple on va traiter
de la relation au nom insectes notamment
aux araignées on va avoir des sorties
nature sur le parc on va avoir aussi une
conférence sur comment et veulent
insectes dans la protection de la nature
les idées reçues on se fait sur notre
relation entre les hommes et des
insectes comment la bei est utilisée par
l'homme aussi notamment d'apiculture
voilà voilà tout ce qu'on va aborder
cette année c'est vraiment tourner
autour de notre relation au monde des
insectes donc tout ça ça se passera à la
maison des insectes de carrières sous
poissy merci beaucoup caroline flick
d'avoir été avec nous par
visioconférence je le rappelle donc ce
dimanche une journée entière consacrée
à la relation entre les amis' ans est la
première de l'année pour les tarifs
c'est le prix de l'entrée normal donc 7
euros et gratuit pour les adhérents
merci à votre invité merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous car l'une pic on a
parlé d'entomologie bixente c'est le
fait de manger des insectes on va rester
dans l'alimentation avec quelque chose
de plus habituel pour les yvelinois will
gregory on est rentré dans notre période
hivernale et qu'est ce qui fait le plus
plaisir en hiver quand il fait bien
froid que de se lever tard et se
préparer un bon brunch grégory
effectivement c'est l'un des musts de
l'hiver voilà ce qui fait encore plus
plaisir c'est de ne pas le préparer du
tout et de se le faire servir au mesnil
saint denis l'épicerie rose et léon
propose tous les samedis son brunch
spécialement habillés aux couleurs et
aux saveurs de l'hiver c'est alice jorda
la gérante qui nous le présente regardez
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue chez les rozes
éléments je suis à l'iss on a créé
l'épicerie il ya quelques temps et on
organise des brunchs tous les week-ends
donc on va vous faire découvrir
aujourd'hui ce qu'on propose aux
couleurs de l'hiver on est en plein
froid il gèle dehors et on propose des
choses vitamines et gourmande c'est le
mot d'ordre d'un brunch et d'oncle avec
un petit clin d'oeil encore plus
gourmand que d'habitude puisque on va
avoir des couleurs connoté donc du coup
hivernale fruits et légumes de saison
bien entendu
[Musique]
alors je vous présente ce concert pour
nos brunch habituellement quelle que
soit la saison on a bien sûr la
charcuterie on travaille beaucoup de
charcuterie étrangères espagnol corse
italienne on a le fromage bien
évidemment on est sur des pâtes dures
des pâtes pressées
pour convenir à tous les goûts du chef
de la vache et c est du coup en cette
pleine saison hivernale
on aime bien proposer des brioches qui
vont être à la cannelle que vous avez là
qui vont délicieusement bien avec le
chat et qui est une boisson lactée au
lait végétal et pis c'est ce qu'on
propose également et qu'on peut faire
toutes les variantes selon la saison
c'est ce qui va être au chocolat et là
on fait des choses aux amandes et
aulnoye c'est une bague qu'un donc là
celle ci est au chocolat amandes noix et
noisettes
on peut faire aux pralines roses on peut
faire à plein de choses plein de goûts
variés les chocolats etc ça c'est ma
préférée parce qu'elle est très sucré et
du coup je connais noir compense un
petit peu et c'est délicieux encore pour
la partie sucré on travaille les fruits
et légumes de saison donc là on est en
deux sur le citron avec des petites
verrines
avec une base sablé alimentaire donc
c'est une crème au citron surmonté de
petites meringues ce que j'ai pas monter
là parce que c'est encore en cuisson au
four c'est tout ce qui va être la partie
chaude qui est essentiel dans un brunch
nous ont fait beaucoup d eau cocotte
donc ce avec une chips dollars soit avec
une tranche de saumon fumé et tout ce
qui va être minutes donc on fait
vraiment devant les gens ou qu'on monte
à la demande si tout ce qui va être
pancakes au potiron ou à la cour chasse
comme on veut surmontée d'une petite
crème aux herbes et ça c'est très très
chouette
donc on vous attend tous les samedis
chez rose et leon le brunch est prêt là
je vous ai présenté un brunch pour 8
personnes aux saveurs de l'hiver avec
des produits de saison
[Musique]
bon là c'est pour une personne mais ça
donne presque envie de manger tout seul
que j'ai très très faim après ce sujet à
bixente pour découvrir ce brunch donc
rendez vous chaque samedi à l'épicerie
rose et leon là c'est un brunch points 8
donc mais c'est adaptable si vous êtes
moins bien entendu pour le prix c'est 25
euros et mieux vaut réserver avant on va
terminer avec d'autres idées de sorties
un agenda à venir et une exposition me
chagrine expo artistique et scientifique
du côté de la celle saint cloud son nom
des arbres et des hommes pour les
amoureux de la nature et les fasciner
comme moi de ces grands anciens de la
forêt dix artistes présentent photos
peintures dessins broderies et gravures
pour témoigner de la beauté et des
secrets de ces géantes de la nature on y
retrace aussi les relations entre et
nous humains les bienfaits qu'ils nous
apportent début ce samedi 15 janvier du
côté du salon de l'hôtel de ville et
l'expo reste jusqu'au 6 mars prochain
avec des ateliers découverte et création
pour les familles prévues les 23 24 et
25 janvier ceux qui veulent écouter de
la musique un concert à bougival cinq
musiciens franciliens investir en le
théâtre du grenier pour rendre hommage à
la célèbre troupe de freddie mercury
queen trois heures de show rien que ça
pour un moment unique le vendredi 21
janvier prochain à 20h45 le billet plein
tarif est à 16 euros réservations sur le
mail réservations points grenier @ ville
tirés bougival point fr idéal pour bien
terminer la semaine voilà grâce à
bixente vous savez comment bien terminer
la semaine et vous avez aussi des idées
pour la semaine d'après on va l'appeler
l'échelle des biches et et les bons
tuyaux dans cette émission qui vous
donne chaque semaine sa sélection
d'idées de sorties merci bixente d'avoir
livré avec nous et merci pour votre
sélection c'est déjà la fin de ce siècle
8 7 8 week-end merci de nous avoir suivi
l'information locale revient dès lundi
en direct à 18h avec le journal de la
rédaction et d'ici là passez un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]